[Music]  safety not guaranteed uh uh critics love  this film as he said you won an award  for this film uh we have a clip here  from the from the movie uh what can you  tell us that help us with the clip this  is right before a dinosaur is about to  eat me  i don't know what's real and what's not  anymore  yeah me neither  i'm just staring at you to just get more  that's all i love it uh okay this is  from a clip from the movie safety not  guaranteed yeah be be aware  this is much more fascinating than the  clip  i love this okay okay here we go a clip  from safety not guaranteed  what time would you go back to  if you could  i don't know  i'm fine here  i would definitely go back  everything cool is gone  aztecs people killing themselves for  each other  you wouldn't want to see the dragons and  the elves fight each other in the  magical forest come on  no  that wasn't a time  [Applause]  yeah  okay  there was no dinosaur  you're so naive  i fell for it